oh my
god um I don't have power I don't have
power I don't have power I don't have
power I have
no I have
no
[Music]
okay okay I'm going call it good on
breakfast I for some reason didn't want
much I don't know cuz I love granola and
yogurt so here's what we have for today
I start my day literally just going over
my main goals and one of them is to go
outside I did not go outside yesterday
second thing is to focus on building out
my app something I've really loved about
this time in my life is I have the
flexibility and like ability to
literally just like pick up whatever
project I want a a few weeks ago I
started building up a dating app with
this like pretty hilarious but like also
ridiculous concept but I also had a
recent idea of like seeing what a
specific like BFE app would look like I
am releasing the BFE blog in a couple of
weeks so I'm so excited I'm really
trying to bring back the more like fun
chill side of it of like yeah let's just
like casually over morning coffee talk
about like the real reason why your code
isn't working spoiler alert it's you
like that just like bring more fun into
it so I'm really excited for that and so
I'm looking at um ways to actually
create or see what creating an app to
accompany that blog would look like so
I'm going to be building that today yeah
and I guess also just like seeing where
the day takes
[Music]
us all right it
is too noisy out there a girl cannot
think so I'm going be here instead this
is insane okay I literally just walked a
couple of steps from the balcony to the
couch and my
chest my heart wants to just break free
of its rib cage I am struggling with
this elevation there's this one churro
place that I love let's find that and
head over all packed up oh
almost can't forget this cuz I will just
pass
[Music]
away okay so I was going to get a churro
then I remembered I
absolutely I'm not the biggest fan of
shur like I came here with all
intent to get
one but I
got ch
I got a chocolate
milkshake instead as I mentioned before
I been spending a hot minute working on
developing apps and that has led me to
look at okay what are the steps when it
comes to app development I would
consider myself a beginner in this
regard with this stuff and being so I
want to share just some things I no
there some things that um yeah I feel
like are soft steps and just
considerations if you're a person who
yeah are looking to develop apps to be
deployed to the public that's another
thing I'm not talking about just
portfolio projects I'm talking about
apps that someone may want deployed out
to the public so the first thing if yeah
you're developing an app by yourself or
maybe you and one other person at least
for me you have to like be able to
picture picture yourself building this
thing for a long long time I spent it's
not going to take this isn't going to
sound like a lot but for a solid seven
days every single moment I was awake I
was building this app I'm a very
impatient person and so I always just
want things done as soon as possible and
so yeah I really hammered down on it and
was just trying to get the peer plane
MVP which is my second um tip When
developing an app it's so easy to think
of the most grand like things that you
can include in it so much so that you
kind of get start getting lost in it
all a big humongous piece of advice I
have is when you have the idea for your
app that you want to create sit down and
literally write out or type out what the
MVP to that app is the MVP is the
minimally viable product and that is
what is the least functionality my app
needs to I to like run or like to be
done a good example of this is like
instacart x amount of years ago somebody
had an idea to create a grocery delivery
app now they didn't start out trying to
develop this
insane app that it is now instead they
said okay what is the goal of the app it
is to align people who want the
groceries delivered with Shoppers and
yeah get their get their stuff deliver
and so what is the MVP of that it is
creat creting a platform where users who
need groceries can log in or just
honestly don't even necessarily need to
log in but like can go on explain in
plain text what items they need one
apple one banana and some cereal in
plain text send it off and then that
information gets received by somebody
willing to shop for those items that's a
pretty basic
MVP and if you were a person who was
starting a grocery delivery app before
it was created that would be the number
one step create a platform where
somebody can input what they need and
then a platform where somebody can see
what somebody needs and then allow for
that process to happen creating an MVP
is so important because very quickly you
can um get a proof of concept with this
very Bare Bones app or platform you're
able to start testing and seeing what
users think about the opportunity to
have somebody shop for their groceries
and see what their input is and what IAL
um risks or hazards or things that um
are getting in the way of that goal and
then you can continue developing
accordingly and that's what's so great
about Agile development it's like okay
we just need to figure things out as
quickly as possible so let's constantly
think of what the MVP is and the second
you get that first MVP done think next
what's the next level of the MVP and
keep going that
[Applause]
way toward the end of your MVP a good
thing start doing is start calculating
cost of what it's going to take to have
your app run there are some apps that
really wouldn't be much cost um but
there are others that would be a lot of
cost for example for me how was Data
being handled and managed having a
secure database is probably the most
important thing that you can have for
your users especially in 2023 and so
it's like okay what um can I do to make
sure that the users informations and
everything if users do need to input
information is being protected I started
using Firebase which was really really
amazing I was actually really shocked at
how quick um and easy to use it was but
after doing some math and it was free
for me to like use it in that um during
MVP stage and testing and things like
that but I started doing some math and
for me to deploy this app and start
housing individuals data it it would
cost tens of thousands of dollarss a
month and so I was
like okay how does one get
such and so that's where looking at
other funding um options is so so
necessary they are really amazing
opportunities and incubator programs
that um take people who are creating
have created um seemingly amazing apps
and work with them to hopefully see it
through success an example of one is
combinator I'm pretty sure many of yall
know about that program and it is
extremely um like competitive but at the
same time it's filled with the brightest
Minds out there Sam Alman from Chad GPT
it can be just
absolutely just an insane opportunity if
that's something you're interested in
definitely check out the applications
and apply and then another way to get
funding is um reaching out to VC firms
um on your own and pitching your idea or
to individual investors and pitching
your idea and in the fourth reaching out
to friends and family and pitching your
idea and seeing if anybody who has the
extra funds to Doo would be willing to
um fund your idea in exchange for some
Equity okay so it suddenly got dark so I
started walking home and then I was like
wait a minute I didn't get any food for
dinner and when I had that thought I saw
a taco place we like okay cool let me
order the second I ordered it started
just
pour okay we made it with very few drops
on us so
let's go I'm at
starving did I order one
taco okay I could cry I am so
hungry okay okay you know what it's fine
it's fine it's fine I'm going to order
I'll order some door Dash they call it R
rappy here
Robie that's what I'll order I'll
microwave this and we
will move forward oh my
God oh my
gosh
okay okay I don't have power okay we're
okay um I don't have power I don't have
power I don't have power I don't have
power I have
no I have
no
okay
okay let
me reach out to my host and okay I
only have like 37% of battery so I need
to conserve this oh my gosh am I going
to die oh my goodness I have one taco I
have water and I have 37% what do I do
hey it
appears I don't have any
power Okay so I will
eat a cold as Taco it's fine I'll
put some lime juice on it my laptop is
at
2% one thing at a time I'm going to put
some lime juice on this I want to
eat it so I'm less hungry and I'll just
go from
there okay
well not much is happening wow wow what
what a plot twist this is fun I'm having
a great time okay here we go oh my gosh
it's so cold it's so cold it's
good pretty salty actually
wo wow that's actually really
salty I sat here ate the Taco homeboy
still hasn't responded so I double
texted and said please advise
at which point um I think the
translation isn't amazing but he was
like how do you think and then okay I'll
see that right
now I think the proper inference of this
message is like oh like oh really you
think
so um okay I'll I'll see to that right
now should I find a
cafe to work from if they have Outlets
like a Starbucks and I saw Starbucks oh
but it was so far that Starbucks was so
far it was during my
walk that was wild the second I clicked
stop recording the lights went on the
second oh I'm so mad I didn't get that
on video ah I'm so mad I didn't get that
okay cool oh thank God it just turns off
again okay let me charge everything I
own right now okay okay that was funny
and well I can say that cuz I'm sitting
here with the lights on and my
charging I need to order some
food and I kind of want to just like
chill for a little bit um so we're
coming on to the end of our day let me
figure out food and hopefully
enjoy this light someone's
knocking I don't want to answer
it it's like a buzz let's see if they bu
Buzz
again let me see if my let me see if my
host like sent a
message
no let
me let me also not be in line with the
door I don't
know okay let's see my Airbnb host is
typing okay he just double checked if
everything's okay like are the lights on
is the Internet working it looks like
the internet was working fine so let me
tell him that but he had he didn't say
that he's buzzing or that he's the one
at the door I don't like this now I'm
thinking I should just like keep the
camera rolling 24/7 cuz the second I
stopped filming something else
happens how annoying is this by the way
it's just frames that's annoying and it
like it's not only just frames it has
the like plas IC wrapping on it okay I
think everything's fine oh my gosh okay
I would have never guessed today would
have been distressful I'm going to order
myself the like best meal I want to
treat myself for the ups and downs of
this day and I'm going to get a nice big
thing of dessert yeah that's what we're
going to do so let's let's do that ah
and now I'm afraid to stop filming
because watch someone like I don't even
want to say it whatever whatever it's
fine it's
fine we
have our food I got some pastas just
some bolog um I think that's how you say
and um teros sou for dessert I feel like
that's a good Comfort pickme up type of
dinner so yeah let's go digging this is
one grain of
past oh my goodness this is a family of
four type of feast
[Music]